un peu plus d'un mois après l incendie
du tunnel du fréjus qui avait provoqué
la mort de deux chauffeurs routiers la
fermeture de l'ouvragé la vallée de la
maurienne n'a jamais été aussi calme
tous les poids lourds étaient détournés
vers le mont blanc ou vernis une
situation d'urgence au départ mais les
élus et les écologistes veulent en
profiter pour tenter de relancer le
ferroutage hervé ghesquière christian
welter déserte
incroyablement désert
l'autoroute a43 vers le tunnel du fréjus
est certainement la moins fréquentée de
france depuis le 4 juin dernier
lincendie et la fermeture du passage
transalpin
l'écologiste philippe de l'homme n'en
croit d'ailleurs pas ses yeux
mais reste lucide derrière tout ça
derrière ce répit qu'il ya une qualité
de vie et que cette qualité de vie il
faut qu'on arrive à l'obtenir rapidement
dans les dix ans à venir je crois qu'il
faudrait qu'on peut diminuer
drastiquement le nombre de poids lourds
et qu'on mette un quota dans chaque
vallée alpine c'est pas seulement un
problème de la vallée de la maurienne ce
un problème de toutes les vallées
alpines des pyrénées des vosges
donc de toutes les vallées de montagnes
qui sont engorgées de camions et de
pollution le ferai juste fermé c'est
plus de 3000 poids lourds par jour des
tournées vers nice où le tunnel du mont
blanc
aux dernières nouvelles le ferai juste
devrait rouvrir plus tôt que prévu fin
août prochain
dans le cas du tunnel du fréjus nous
avions déjà tiré les enseignements de
lundi 2 mars 99 du tunnel du mont-blanc
de vos équipements et déjà été mis en
place
il s'agit là simplement de les remplacer
de les remettre en état
localement dans la région de modane les
camions empruntent le col du mont-cenis
la vieille nationale 6 une forte pente
la montagne la vraie 2000 mètres
d'altitude
ça nous change de prendre le col par
rapport aux tunnels ou point de vue tant
et puis bon vin dans un autre sens aussi
mode patrons ils économisent des sous
sur le prix du tunnel le bon comme ça
change à peu le paysage est
l'alternative
ce serait le chemin de fer nous sommes
ici dans la galerie de service du futur
tunnel ferroviaire franceet l 52 km sous
les halles pour une grande ligne lyon /
problème
le projet n'est pas encore totalement
financé il faut trouver 13 milliards
d'euros si nous ne réalisons pas cet
ouvrage nous prenons le risque demain
d'un phénomène de thrombose dans le
massif alpin et je dirais aussi une
révolte profonde des populations qui
n'en peuvent plus aujourd'hui d'un
trafic routier qui n'a fait que
s'accroître et dont les risques sont
chaque jour plus important mais
l'autoroute ferroviaire sera mise en
service au plus tôt en 2020 d'ici là les
vallée de chamonix et de maurienne
verront encore passer des millions de
camions jeu